I would like to first and foremost thank
the judge for granting me this
restraining order to protect me and I'm
just gonna get back to co-parenting
dreams blac chyna was granted a
restraining order against ex-fiance Rob
Kardashian Wednesday this after Rob had
shared private nude photos of her she
walked out with a big smile on her face
she gave me lots of hugs I think it was
like a huge weight was lifted off of her
shoulders Rob has been ordered to stay
away from China and is not allowed to
post any photos of her on social media
China's lawyer Lisa bloom tells ET the
two will still be sharing custody of
dream China is very happy to share
custody fifty-fifty with Rob as she has
been she's not concerned about dream
being around Rob right now she has said
he's a good father
there are nannies around when the baby
is with him and she hasn't had any
reason to be concerned
China is aware that Rob is the father of
her baby she's not trying to start a war
bloom says right now China is not
pursuing criminal charges next steps she
says is to figure out a formal
visitation schedule for dream still she
says China is waiting on what she calls
a real apology from wrong I think the
appropriate place for him to issue that
apology would be on the same social
media where he attacked her
[Music]